foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
speaking of the tournament Wally zerbiak
back in 1999 at Miami of Ohio as it was
called back then got to the Sweet 16
college basketball analyst for CBS and
an analyst for the Knicks as well what
was it like after the first weekend
back in 1999 when you go back to campus
how crazy is it and are you treated
differently
absolutely
um you know coming from a small school
like Miami you know obviously we had a
good senior season and we were winning
basketball game so we had sellouts at
our Arena but when we got back I
remember at like one in the morning
after uh flying home from New Orleans
there was a bunch of students waiting
for us right in front of the Arena when
we were going into our locker room it
was absolute pandemonium I remember the
next day heading to class it was just
like I've never felt more like a rock
star than those couple days on campus
I mean honestly it was amazing it was a
whirlwind also with a lot of interviews
our sports information director did a
great job of organizing our interviews
because there was a lot of national
stuff coming in and we just needed to
still stay focused on winning because we
had a game to play on Thursday that week
against uh Kentucky in the sweet 16. so
it was a memorable week memorable time
and one all cherish and never forget who
was on Kentucky at that time they had a
great team uh Jamal mcgloor came off the
bench taishan Prince
um Saul Smith uh
Keith bogan's
um Wayne Turner I mean they had like uh
Bradley was the center that started uh
Scott Padgett I think they had five six
pros and I think they ended up losing
the Michigan State though in the
regional final to go to the final four
what advice would you give Florida
Atlantic or Princeton because you can
surprise people maybe one game maybe two
now you get a week to prepare for
Princeton and Florida Atlantic
um well I think what they're doing
they're very capable they have to just
play their game and play at a high level
what I've been so impressed with was
Princeton is they went up against one of
the biggest strongest most physical and
size dominant teams in the NCAA
tournament in Arizona in the whole
entire country quite frankly and they
out rebounded them and they also had six
blocks to their one so to me that shows
that they can match up physically size
wise strength wise you know all those
controllable kind of Statistics where
normally a smaller school will get
dominated on the boards they'll look
small they'll be getting their shots
blocked when they go into the paint but
as far as Princeton goes that's not how
it was in their second round game they
completely dominated that game too they
dominated the boards big time so I think
if they just continue to play their game
play physical they have a great chance
to move on because that team is old that
team is mature that team is seasoned
that team has been in really really
close games every single year it seems
like they're in a final possession game
to make it to the NCAA tournament
against Yale against Cornell against uh
who knows you know one of those other
schools that are in the ivy league that
are really top-notch basketball so
Florida Atlantic the same way they're an
old mature team they bring a bunch of
guys off the bench that can really play
well you look at these games Michigan
state is now favored against K-State
Arkansas uh getting four and a half
against Connecticut Florida Atlantic
hitting five against Tennessee and
Gonzaga is getting one and a half
against UCLA what do you think happens
in those games
um listen uh I I would I you know Tom
Izzo you know in in March the only team
left standings in the Big Ten it's
incredible what he's able to get his
teams to do you know come the NCAA
tournament I kept my eye on them all
season long honestly I thought they were
going to really peek at the end because
they have a really talented roster they
fit very well and you know I I would
have to pick them in that game uh I
think the zags are going to get UCLA I
just think UCLA is too banged up
um you know they've had some injuries
they're dealing with they're a little
bit thin they're a really tough team
though so UCLA is going to have to be
ready to battle especially on the
interior and on the boards but I think I
like UCLA in that one I like Florida
Atlantic I just think Tennessee without
Sakai Ziegler they totally just
you know made it a street fight against
Duke and they just punked him they
really did I mean Duke did not handle
the physicality well Duke is a freshman
type team a little bit inexperienced and
when Tennessee got their got their mitts
on him and really manipulated them
physically I think uh you know they're
not going to be able to do that against
Florida Atlantic so I like Florida
Atlantic in that one and the last one
Arkansas is a is an outstanding
basketball game I mean that's going to
be a really fun one so um I would think
I think Arkansas can pull off that upset
you know what they did against Kansas
Coach Musselman is a tremendous NCAA
tournament coach he's a great in-game
coach with the sports bars in-game
adjustments go they have freshmen that
are really talented that are playing to
really Elevate their stock in the NBA
Draft so I think I like Arkansas now
okay let me go back to Gonzaga and UCLA
you like you like Gonzaga to get UCLA
because they're banged up I do okay I do
I think the zags are flying under the
radar you know they've made it to the
championship game I don't know if
they're that good to win it all this
year but I don't think a lot of people
realize how good they are because they
haven't been number one number two all
season long you know like they've been
the last couple Seasons they've been
floating around 12 13 15 but they were
playing in a really good League the West
Coast Conference was a lot better than
spending years past so I think the zags
get that one we're talking to Wally
zerbiak CBS college basketball analyst
should John Keller Perry be on the hot
seat
I don't think so
um I just think John Calipari over the
years you know he's had to kind of
adjust to the landscape of college
basketball and right now the landscape
of college basketball is completely
changing and you know I think you did a
pretty good job this year they were a
couple made threes away from being in
the sweet 16 again he always gets his
teams playing well at the end of the
season I think he's got a retool and I
think with the new rules the transfer
portal the nil I don't know why you
wouldn't want to go play in Kentucky so
he should have his pick of what players
um you know to have moving forward and
with his track record his success in
years past I don't think there's any
reason to move on from him from John
Calipari I think he's a great coach what
are your expectations for Rick Pitino at
St John's
wow I am excited I just saw a tweet that
popped up on my timeline he said any
former players who want to stop by
um the campus and watch workouts this
summer you're more than welcome and I'm
going to reach out to Rick and be like
Rick you know I didn't play there I
would have loved to but I wasn't
recruited by you guys but you know St
John's is deep in my heart you know
that's the team I rooted for growing up
as a kid all those St John's teams
um you know with Chris Mullen and
Company Malik Seeley and all those teams
coach karneseka just you know the Big
East when it was really rolling is the
Big East so I am just ecstatic that Rick
got the job it's about time that St
John's is competitive again at a
national level the Big East is a
wonderful conference to watch and it
continues to get better and better and I
think adding coach Cooley to Georgetown
and Rick Pitino to St John's only
elevates that conference even more and I
can't wait to be a part of it and go to
games at the Garden and I hope that uh
St John's can get back to the tournament
and start winning some game in the NCAA
tournament when you were in the NBA and
there would be calls that you know Stars
would get there'd be
favoritism
how often would that happen where you go
wait I didn't I didn't touch Jordan why
am I getting called for a foul
uh you know I I gotta be honest I think
when I played I had no issue with the
referees uh when you look back at my
career I maybe only had two or three
technicals in 10 years I just felt like
our referees were the best on the planet
uh you were able to sit down and you'd
not sit down you were able to go over to
them and talk to them they're able to
discuss things the rules were laid out
very very fairly I think um one of the
reasons why there are some issues with
refereeing now is there is a little bit
of a turnover and there is some change
some of those veterans officials that I
was you know was officiating my games 15
years ago they've kind of moved on
they've retired they've gone up into
different you know uh uh uh job
descriptions and stuff like that and it
takes time as an NBA official to build a
chemistry with the players you have to
get used to how certain guys play you
have to get used to when you know James
Harden gets contact when Trey young gets
contact and you have to have experience
and I think that's one of the issues
that's going on right now another thing
is this the few tweaks and rules that
they continue to make each summer
I think it kind of throws the players
and it throws the referees off because
you know they start calling it a certain
way at the beginning of the Season then
come playoff time it becomes way more
physical and they let all that stuff go
and coaches are on their Sidelines
saying to themselves where's the
consistency of how the game was being
called at the beginning of the season to
now so I think the main thing and I talk
no Tom Thibodeau talks about it all the
time in his press conferences he just
wants it consistent he wants the same
call made for both teams on both ends
and then you can't say a word and the
officials are trying their best they're
held to a very high criteria but I just
think it takes experienced officials to
really get those close calls right
did you face Jordan Kobe and LeBron
oh yeah oh yeah I I was three years
against Jordan when he was in Washington
with the Wizards so fortunately you know
we used to get some wins against those
guys when I was with the Timberwolves we
played him twice and then Kobe we faced
him in the playoffs three times with
Kobe and chat they knocked us knocked us
out of the Western Conference Finals
second round and first round in like
three out of five years when I was with
the Timberwolves and then LeBron yeah of
course I played against him in Cleveland
and I played with him in Cleveland for
two years in 0809 the difference between
those three
is on the court is what yeah well there
are three of the top of all time
um
I still put uh Jordan as number one just
because every time he had to win a game
he did uh and the dominance that he had
over that era winning six championships
and six years with the six opportunities
I mean that is just unbelievable to me
and he had that the mental game I think
was Second To None did he make you
nervous did he scare you
no no he didn't because again when I saw
him it was in Washington and you know he
wasn't quite the same dominant Force
okay you know you would go into
Washington and you would think okay we
can get a win because they weren't a
great team you know they were maybe 500
team sub 500 team so there wasn't fear
at that point what about prime Kobe
now I feel fear Jordan on the golf
course when I play with him down in
Florida he instills feared me down there
that's for sure because he could play
and we're both four handicaps and he
kicks my butt because I'm not used to
Florida golf how about prime Kobe
um no I think
who instilled more fear in me and our
team was Shaq honestly you know they
complimented each other wonderfully
obviously but
um Shaq was the guy that we really
feared on The Scouting Report
um you know Kobe obviously was going to
make the big shots down the stretch but
you needed a game plan for Shaq like
there was just no Force like that
um ever and uh you know he just
dominated the interior and if you didn't
have three guys ready to double team him
when he caught the ball he was going to
score every time he touched it any
downside to being LeBron's teammate
no LeBron was an outstanding teammate he
was an outstanding father outstanding
friend outstanding teammate absolutely
loved my time with him in Cleveland
um he brought out the best in me
especially at that point in my career
when I was kind of on the downturn
dealing with injuries couldn't play a
lot of minutes but I had a great role as
a three-point shooter and a stretch four
man and we had a great season winning 66
games so uh Lebron is a joy to be with
as a person off the floor as his
teammate and also obviously on the floor
he makes everyone better I know that
you're an analyst for the New York
Knicks how real are the Knicks this year
oh they're real I'm telling you
um they continue to surprise me it seems
like every night out this team just
keeps getting better their average age
is 23 and a half years old Jalen Brunson
has been one of the best free agent
signings in New York Sports history he
has completely transformed this
franchise turned around this franchise
solidified the point guard position
which has been an issue with the Knicks
for seems like 15 years and Julius
randles back to playing like a first
second team all-nba player so uh it's
going to be interesting to see what they
can do in the playoffs but getting back
into the playoffs as a start and we'll
see if they can win a couple rounds good
to talk to you Wally have fun today we
appreciate you joining us anytime Dan
all the best Wally zerbiak CBS Sports
we'll take a break we'll update our poll
results and we have our play of the day
coming up next year Dan Patrick Show